before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
I've been putting this one off
for a long time
[Music]
hey there folks yes it's finally time
for me to properly
redo my ranking of the doctors on Doctor
Who
I've been putting this off for a while
because basically people have been
asking me pretty much since the end of
series 11 will you do it again and put
Jody Whitaker's doctor in and the answer
that I gave him that I stuck with was
that not until I'm confident where she's
going to land and that probably won't
happen until the end of her run now full
disclosure at time of recording power of
the doctor has not aired yet so she
technically has one more appearance even
though I'm gonna do the list now but I
don't expect that my entire opinion of
her in the part is going to change based
off one episode
so the other things to keep in mind one
this is my opinion only and with the
exception of the very last on the list
the very bottom spot I don't think any
of these are bad or poorly done in terms
of the writing
they just aren't what I prefer and since
I mentioned the writing that's the other
thing to keep in mind what this rank is
meant to be is a rank of the doctor as a
character and the way that they were
portrayed not of the episodes they
appeared in in other words it is
possible for a very good doctor to have
appeared in very bad stories or for a
doctor who I maybe don't like as much as
other people who appeared in Amazing
Stories this is not a rank of errors as
a whole only of the doctors themselves
okay that having all been established
we've got 15 of these to go I've got two
to add on to the last time I did it so
let us get started with
number 15.
the War Doctor
this is the only one that I feel like to
me just never fully worked part of this
is because John Hurt as iconic as he is
and he's not bad in Day of the Doctor
but he doesn't get much to do it's not
really about him so that doesn't really
give him that much of an opportunity to
shine Beyond just the actor's raw
Charisma which John Hurt had a very
unique kind of Charisma so that
definitely helps but that's pulling a
lot of weight for a character who is not
granted a ton to actually do now I've
tried I've tried to find stuff that
would get me to like him better I
there's still plenty of big finish stuff
with John Hurt that I have not listened
to but I have listened to some of it
and it didn't turn me around on the
character
I just he's the least interesting
iteration of the doctor to me I will
still seek out more of the War Doctor
because even the worst doctor to me is a
doctor worth spending some time with but
I've never found anything that really
clicked with him for me so
there it is
number 14.
uh before I say who this is it's worth
noting that both this one and the next
one are this low for very similar
reasons in that I feel like I never
fully got them there would be moments
here and there would be like oh that's
starting to click and I think I
understand you but like for some reason
I just wasn't able to properly connect I
never felt like I really just gelled
with them and got on their wavelength
and oftentimes found myself going
I don't get you I don't fully get your
deal and that's why they're down here
and the first of these two is the Fifth
Doctor Peter Davison first of all is a
very lovely man I've met him he was
wonderful his doctor
especially in his time uh on the show I
just find difficult to connect with part
of this is probably at least partially
due to an issue that I've talked about
elsewhere which is I don't feel like he
has a definitive companion and even if
you have your favorite companion of the
fifth doctor's era he never built that
core relationship and I'm realizing now
that a big part of how I connect with a
doctor is through how their relationship
with the companion Works which honestly
might be part of my issue with the War
Doctor as well but he doesn't really
have that and even the big finished
stuff that I've listened to some of
which again is quite good like spare
parts is great
he's not the strongest thing for it at
least not for me he's not the bits of
those stories that I'm connecting with
the most and the number of times that he
like clicks and I'm like oh
I get it they are not
completely absent
but they're few and far between
and like I have people who I'm very
close with who love him and I'm really
happy for them I I wish I saw it I just
I just kind of don't
number 13.
the 13th Doctor
with Jody Whitaker similarly to Peter
Davison's Fifth Doctor
I just oftentimes feel like I don't get
her like the character is not letting me
in and again saddling her immediately
with three companions really meant that
I never felt there was a core
relationship there it's kind of become
Yaz by default but the the show didn't
do a lot to properly build them just put
them in the same room a lot of times I
never felt like I fully understood that
relationship even when they started to
be more explicit about where they were
going with it
the reason she's above number five above
the fifth doctor is because she does
have a few more instances that I've seen
where I did connect with I was like ooh
like that's not just Exposition that's
not just technobabble that's just not
saying the plan that is that is
characterization that I get
I really want there to have been more
than there was but there is more of it
that I've had from her than from
Davidson now to be fair
I've seen all of Whitaker's stuff and I
haven't seen all of Davidson's I've seen
a very decent chunk of it but there's
still some I haven't seen so maybe when
I've seen all of Davidson's I'll have
found more moments and he'll end up
above her at a later point but right now
at time of recording that's where they
land and also I should have said this at
the front end like don't assume that you
now know where everything else is
because of where it was last time I did
this things change I didn't go back and
check what the order was last time so
I'm not trying to keep it consistent my
answer to these things often changes
over time so let us move on to
number 12.
The Fugitive doctor
Joe Martin's Charisma as soon as she's
on screen grabbed me and I immediately
wanted more of her
we got very little of more of her the
reason I put her above Whitaker is
because I did feel like I got her pretty
much immediately and I never felt like I
lost that connection with what she was
doing and how she was portraying the
doctor
unfortunately while that puts her above
Whitaker simply because the percentage
of her time on screen I felt like I got
her a heck of a lot better than ended up
being the case with Whitaker she is
still not there very much I have a
sneaking suspicion
that uh as she works with big finish and
more stuff comes out there and I listen
to that she is liable to creep her way
up the list from here but right now
she's where she is largely because of a
lack of material but wow wow do I want
more of her
number 11.
the first doctor it's worth noting at
this point as you should have guessed
from how I talked about Joe Martin we're
kind of out of the ones that I'm like on
and even the ones that I that I was like
I wasn't that harsh I don't think I was
anyways but like from here on out I like
all of these honestly I even like
Davison and Whitaker just less but these
are all good it's just a matter of
preference and for me while I enjoy
quite a bit the first doctor specially
in certain stories
the the way the mystery was built around
him and how crotcheting grumpy he was at
the start just didn't it's lacking that
warmth now he did develop that warmth
over time and one could even argue it's
something of an arc for the character
possibly but he's still uh a little bit
often detached from what's going on a
little bit in a way that makes it a
little bit harder for me to root for him
I'll tell you what though every now and
then
he gets something really spot on like
that moment in I forget which episode of
the war machines it is but where he's
everyone's running and he just walks
towards the towards the machines that
are destroying everything he does have
his moments like that and they are great
again just kind of wish there were more
of them
number 10.
the Third Doctor
again this is pure preference because
first of all John perch we one of the
most charismatic men who ever lived he
brings
amazing energy to this part and like you
just gravitate towards him you just want
to be around him and he's just got that
smile that lights up the room and he's
mischievous at times the reason he's not
higher than he is is because his is the
James Bond of doctors his is the more
action and Gadget focused and that's
just not kind of what I come to Doctor
Who for
I actually have a problem with like the
Venetian uh Aikido that he does but
it's just not what I come to Doctor Who
for and so as a result he ends up down
here even though like boy
oh that man could command the screen
number nine
the eighth doctor and this and also
another one a little bit later should be
illustrative of what I said before about
Joe Martin where I expect some big
finish to bring her up the list because
the eighth doctor
didn't have a lot going for him because
as far as Canon firm fixed Cannon stuff
there's the movie which he is good in
but is not good and then there is Night
of the doctor which is amazing
and there's only about seven minutes
long as ages
what if I get bored or need a television
a couple of books anyone but chess but
then there's all the big Finnish stuff
he kind of was in a lot of ways big
finishes homegrown doctor yes he had
already played the part he was a Canon
doctor before big finish started working
with him but they got to shape him way
more than any of the others and as a
result his stories are really well
tailored to him and to have him build
the relationships that he builds with
the companions makes it so easy to just
fall in love with them
he's Suave he's dashing he's just got
this you can you can hear and like you
have to hear because you don't see him
in big vid you can hear him thinking all
the time like this never stops he's
always got an eye out
oh he's really good
but other things are higher because I
like them even more like this this
should give you an idea of how much I
love Doctor Who I'm in like this
middling area of the list and I'm
talking about how much I love these so
like yeah I love this show and I love
most of these let's move on though
number eight
controversial one the Tenth Doctor David
Tennant so okay
I've explained this before but I will do
it again
I enjoy David Tennant as the doctor I'm
looking forward to see what is going on
in the 60th anniversary when we see him
again
I like a lot of his era
however if I'm detaching him from his
era and looking at just him
he's a little more human than I like the
doctor to be I like the doctor to be a
little bit strange a little bit alien
which is something that certain
performers bring just by the presence
that they have and others make very
deliberate acting choices that lean into
that tenant is the most human in his
choices his acting choices and the way
that he responds to situations and
connects with people and that's not a
flaw it's a feature it's just not to my
preference and narratively it makes
total sense because at this point he
still thinks that gallifrey's gone he's
basically adopted Earth as a new home
he's gone native a little bit it makes
total sense and there's nothing wrong
with it
it's just not my preference and I like
my doctors a little more alien
he is and honestly is probably part of
why he's as popular as he is he is the
most relatable the most human
of the doctors I feel
and for me that's just
lacking something that I really like
otherwise
he's still real good
and again quite charismatic in the part
number seven
the sixth doctor once more big finish
did a lot of work to get me to like the
sixth doctor and some of my favorite big
finish stuff features the sixth doctor
the main thing that they did brilliantly
was match him with fantastic companions
especially Evelyn Smythe but just in
general they knew who to put him with
that could temper his harsher edges that
were on full and at times painful
display during Colin Baker's time
actually on the show so if I were going
only by the show he'd be down towards
the bottom he'd honestly probably be
beneath Davison but I'm not only going
about the show
and I know how good Colin Baker is in
the part
when he is not written to be unlikable
when you get a way to connect with him
he is
amazing and he still has that edge he
never loses that sense of danger but it
stops overtaking the part to the point
that you can't connect relate or root
for him all that well which is what
happened on the show
if you don't get the appeal of Colin
Baker the two big finish that I'm going
to recommend you seek out are Jubilee
and holy Terror holy Terror being my
personal favorite big finish story that
I've heard so far seek those out and if
you are ever going to get the sixth
doctor those should get you there
number six
the 11th doctor
the very first time I did this list and
did this ranking he was my number one
I think there's a couple of reasons why
he was higher than than he is now I can
admittedly to a certain extent be what I
call prisoner of the moment the thing
that is the newest feels the most
special in a way and at the time I did
this list he was the most recent doctor
and in addition to that Matt Smith is my
age
so while he was the doctor it felt like
I could be the doctor
he's the same age as me that's not as
much a factor now because
I'm older and the doctor
Remains the Same visual age when I go
back and see those things so that
specific element of the connection sort
of faded with time and
I love these again the sense of the
weirdness he brought back the weird the
aliens the alienness the not responding
to things quite the way you would expect
a person to do it he brought that back
that I was missing with tenant and I do
love it but as time has gone on I've
just grown into a greater appreciation
of others over him
but I do deeply enjoy his energy I
really like to see how he can turn on
time even when he gets angry he is so
compelling he's really really good he's
not my number one anymore and honestly
he slipped a fair bit but
never lost my love for him
top five here we go number five
the second doctor
Patrick trouton
the thing is as much as William Hartnell
was the initial template that started
everything off
most of the character aspects that I
love the most about the doctor
were introduced by trouton
the instinctive response of danger at
first glance to run away the not only
willing to let his enemies see him as a
buffoon and an idiot but to lean into
that so that they underestimated him and
they didn't know what he was capable of
to always kind of have an eye out and
have a sense of what's going on but to
not be afraid to just be silly and to be
kind
I think a lot of his moments in Tomb of
the Cybermen which is a story that
aspects of which have not aged well but
his performance especially taking time
to talk to Victoria about you know the
life that they lead in the Tardis our
lives are different to anybody else is
that's the exciting thing it's this
sweet familial relationship and moment
that he has with her but at the same
time he can jump right back into the
action at a moment when he run if you
see him running you follow him he ran
away because that's what you should be
doing and he's fun and he's silly but he
knows that this is serious and he takes
what he does seriously but he is allowed
to be
silly a clown even
but he's a clown who's going to save the
Universe
I really love that
number four
the Ninth Doctor
there's another one that initially I
think part of what hurt my earlier
assessments of the Ninth Doctor had to
do with how short Christopher Wilson was
was in the part and in addition to that
I think for a while I kind of Affiliated
his doctor with series one which I do
think has a lot of growing pains in it
but if I do what I sat at the start I
try to do with this list which is to
detach the doctor from his era and just
look at him as a character how is this
character handled
Christopher Eccleston
is wonderful he brings
simultaneously a sense of warmth a
longing for connection but also that
sense of damage and Trauma that he would
have coming immediately after the time
War
for what went on there and what at the
time that his Incarnation is around what
he thinks he did he's gonna have a lot
to deal with
but he's also still going to try and do
the right thing still try and find
someone that he can bring some light and
joy into their life and that can maybe
bring a little into his
there's a lot of layers a lot of
complexity to eccleston's doctor and yes
he has bolstered somewhat by the fact
that I got to meet him briefly granted
but I really felt a connection
going and hearing him talk at panels
seeing him to seeing him respond to how
much everyone was so excited and happy
that he was there and how much everyone
loved him
is that a little bit of an outside force
influencing my opinion of him in the
character part Maybe
but it up to my enjoyment
and I love and appreciate him more now
than I think I ever did
and I'm okay with that
number three
Tom Baker the fourth doctor
oh iconic for a reason and uh again
a bit like Matt Smith and uh Patrick
Troutman before him
you know
bringing the weird just this presence
this sense about him like something's
off about that guy
something something doesn't quite land
out something's weird this guy's weird
why is he weird hello there
because he's not human
he can empathize with humans he can show
sympathy he can show anger he can do all
that stuff but it's not going to be
quite in the way that you would expect
from anybody else
his Joy especially in his earlier
seasons is infectious
he just brings a lightness while again
always treating the situations is
serious but willing to take a villain
down a peg with a joke
well
you're a beautiful woman probably the
look The Presence Tom Baker was really
poured into this role
he was the exact right fit at the exact
right time and he became for so many
people and for so long the iconic image
of the doctor for a good reason
he's amazing
I do have two above him though
number two
the Seventh Doctor Sylvester McCoy
he's been inching his way up the
rankings for me over time and as I get
to experience more of his classic
stories and also some of his big finish
I love
this doctor
I feel like if you were to try to sum
him up in a nutshell it would be like if
Loki was the doctor
he's always scheming he's always
planning but like uh Patrick trouton
very willing to lean into aspects of
himself so that his opponents think he's
an idiot
but it's also not strictly an act
s of him he's a little bit just like
that
but as he makes you wonder
if he's even something to take seriously
as a threat
he has that dark streak he has that
Machiavellian plotting going on the back
of his head
he's doing something silly to distract
you while he comes up with a way to
completely dismantle anything and
everything that you are trying to do and
have ever hoped to accomplish
unlimited rice pudding
Etc when the Seventh Doctor wins it is
very completely because that is how
thoroughly he dismantles those who stand
in his way
and yet he's also lovable
and a big part of this is his
relationship with Ace she is not his
only companion companion but by far his
definitive companion and that
relationship does a lot for both of them
as characters and for him to have
clearly like this is his companion very
cleanly very clearly
that definitive relationship boosts him
up a lot because like I said through the
nature of that relationship I understand
who a doctor is all the better and I
really feel like I get Sylvester McCoy's
doctor
partially thanks to that relationship
and the more time I spend with him
the more I love him
but the number one spot for anyone who
isn't new to the channel should not
actually be a surprise so let's do that
number one
Peter Capaldi
the 12th doctor the man that stops the
monsters
I'm not gonna say it's impossible
for somebody to topple him from the top
spot
because I probably thought at some point
at some points oh no one will ever be
better than Matt Smith to me
but I think of how strongly I connect
with Peter Capaldi and how much he is
really my platonic ideal
of the doctor
in terms of willingness to be a little
silly
that somewhat harsher dark Edge
underneath it that doesn't overwhelm the
character but is always there
in terms of the focus on kindness and
having him realizing how important that
needs to be be part of his journey he
has more of an arc than most doctors I
would argue more than any other doctor
some other doctors do have arcs his his
is really important to me and if you
want a full breakdown on that I did a
video
and part of it has to do with my looking
at it through a queer lens as a
as a gender fluid trans Femme queer
person
but his journey
of being so uncertain of who he was in
his first series
to thinking he knew who he was and
leaning into it so hard that it was
honestly a little bit cringe-worthy in
his second series to then finding the
balance and not only finding the balance
finding the balance with a new companion
so that he could settle in and really
just be who he was supposed to be and be
that comfortably to the point that he is
clutching so tightly
when the idea comes up that he might
have to regenerate again and lose this
journey and lose the person he's become
I can't keep on being somebody else his
performance in and of itself is already
so good but that Journey that that
doctor goes through means so much to me
I have a hard time imagining somebody
coming in above him
it still might happen
but right now
before we get new doctors that people
will start asking me again when are you
going to integrate shittigatawa like I
don't no he's not we haven't even seen
him yet but for right now
at this point
capalities at the top
and that's the list
what do you think of it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills I want to hear your
thoughts I want to hear your ranking
like share subscribe also help but
ultimately I really want you to remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lafolla Tarak the theme that goes joint
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leo the boy toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobelax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam
RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan Larose
and TT thank you for your support if you
want to hear me try and say your name
while this little guy tries to chew on
my earrings well you can check out the
patreon or the support tears that get
you a shout out thanks so much you are a
pain in my butt
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]